[Music]
walking down this quiet street in
brooklyn
you'd never know that inside this
building within this tiny apartment
music is made
meet evan
and luke they're long time friends and
roommates evan and i have been living
together here for
how many years have we landed together
man about a year and a half year and a
half
and once a month in only about 500
square feet they managed to pile in up
to 60 musicians for the ultimate
recording session i think we should put
five or six people in the bathroom
[Music]
for each arrangement we record it in
about three hours and post it online
[Music]
a lot of people's reactions are that it
seems crazy and it is crazy to pull this
off first they have to uproot their
humble abode anything that is not
involved in making music has to go
we take all the furniture out we take
most of the doors off it's just all
about making as much room and as much
sight lines as possible it really just
looks like chaos there's mic stands
everywhere the floor is littered with
music stances
i'm a little worried about this though
there's not a single inch to spare and
that's because they make way for the
strings woodwinds
horns
percussion and a full chorus
yeah that's a marimba in the kitchen
but why i wanted an opportunity to
record a bunch of people at the same
time luke wanted an opportunity to hear
his arrangements played and so we just
invited a bunch of people over and
although it seems unconventional there's
a reason for the madness we're trying to
change the way that you might see an
orchestra play there is a special
dynamic and a feeling in the room that
you won't get in a recording studio or
in a public venue
it's this unique sound and sense of
community that has attracted musicians
from all over the country to participate
there's definitely something really
exciting about the idea that this
shouldn't really be possible it's a
really unique experience and i think
that people are drawn to that and so
they keep at it
[Music]
it's a real uh kind of jarring wonderful
experience every time the movies love it
and i bet the neighbors must love it too
they're lucky they're good
[Applause]
[Music]
you